l'autre grand titre de l'actualité je
vous le disais c'est nouvelle
déclaration attribuée à oussama ben
laden qui a revendiqué les attentats du
11 septembre à la veille des
commémorations un document sonore
diffusé par la chaîne de télévision al
jazira revenons sur la préparation
minutieuse des attentats du 11 septembre
qui ont fait je le rappelle environ 3000
morts une tragédie que personne n'a vu
venir les américains sont encore
stupéfaite savoir que quelques 19
pirates de l'air présumés étaient
parfaitement intégrés dans la société
américaine
un an après le point sur l'enquêté
stéphanie perez 24 heures après les
attaques
l'amérique peut déjà mettre des visages
derrière l'horreur quatre commandos
suicides 19 kamikazes
une minutieuse préparation qui fait
rétrospectivement frémir le pays
ils ont entre 20 et 35 ans des saoudiens
pour la plupart ces hommes surgi de
nulle part
sont entrés le plus légalement du monde
aux états unis leur vie est un modèle
d'infiltration en floride où la majorité
résident depuis l'année 2000 leurs
voisins de delray beach
les décrivent comme discret calme
inséparables quand j'ai vu la photo de
l'un des deux le barbu j'étais en colère
il se baladait ici comme si de rien
n'était alors qu'ils allaient tuer des
milliers de personnes
comment peut-on faire ça pavin soupçons
sur le plan de guerre qui se prépare
tous prennent des leçons de pilotage ici
en floride ou en arizona
sans être jamais inquiétées des cours
payé en liquide une cinquantaine
d'heures de vol chacun suffisamment pour
maîtriser un boeing
les apprentis pilotes ne semblent pas
très doué selon leur instructeur mais
déterminé
c'était difficile de comprendre
réellement leur motivation et c'était
d'autant plus difficile que la limite il
ne visait pas un but précis il voulait
pas devenir pilote professionnel il ne
voulait pas devenir
il voulait pas être lâché voler seul il
voulait simplement progresser par un but
que sur le moment personne ne comprenait
le chef présumé du groupe le voici
mohammed atta un égyptien de 33 ans
s'est vraisemblablement à l'université
de hambourg en allemagne que le complot
a pris forme à ta y est étudiant en
urbanisme à partir de 92
ils rencontrent sur le campus de des
futurs pirates de l'air l'emirati marwan
al shehhi et le libanais ziad jarrah
film est ici lors d'un mariage
ces étudiants pieux mais parfaitement
intégré bascule dans un islamisme
radical leurs parents désemparés ont du
mal à comprendre
il est innocent dans la somme et les
autres quelqu'un a dû voler à quebecor
spn ou utiliser son nom nous ne sommes
pas des extrémistes
selon les enquêteurs c'est le nouvel
ennemi de l'amérique
oussama ben laden qui alimente
financièrement ata et ses complices par
le biais de virement bancaire apte à lui
réfléchir aux modes d'action en mai 2000
il se renseigne tranquillement auprès du
ministère de l'agriculture pour acheter
un avion d'épandage agricole
les kamikazes auraient d'abord envisagé
une attaque chimique sur new york
il voulait acheter un bimoteur d'une
capacité de six passagers et aux
télésièges
il voulait construire un réservoir
chimiques à l'intérieur de l'avion qui
occuperait chaque centimètre carré
possible à l'exception de l'endroit où
le pilote serait assis et et 2001 les
quatre commandos sont positionnés en
floride en californie et au nord-est
la date du 11 septembre leur est
communiquée par mail
nom de code pour les tours jumelles
faculté d'urbanisme pour le pentagone
faculté des arts l'arrestation en août
du français zacarias moussaoui 20e
pirate présumé n'alerte pas les
autorités toujours discrètement
plusieurs missions de reconnaissance
sont effectués à l'aéroport de boston
nous serons détourné deux avions la
voiture des kamikazes il sera retrouvé
tous avancent vers la mort sans
sourciller dans les bagages data on
retrouvera ses dernières recommandations
la veille de l'action tu doit prier bien
aiguisé à l'âme pour qu'elle coupe la
victime quand l'heure de la mort
approchera accueille là avec joie le 11
septembre atteints en barque sans
encombre à l'aéroport de portland aucune
fébrilité apparente dans quelques heures
il propulsera le vol 11 d'american
airlines dans la tour nord du world
trade center